des tombes de navires comme celle-ci, elles
n'ont pas été fouillées depuis 100 ans au
moins en norvège,
la dernière était la découverte d'osberg
en 1904,
c'est que les conditions de conservation de
cette découverte de yelesta ne sont pas aussi
bonnes que, par exemple, l'osberg le
gokstar ou le  des navires tuner
où le bois était encore préservé et
ce sont des objets de musée uniques
[Musique]
nous croirions que les personnes enterrées
dans une telle situation que
comme celle-ci, cela doit
provenir des tueurs supérieurs de la société au moins
je dirais peut-être  un roi ou une reine
ou un yarl peut-être au moins quelqu'un de
très haut placé dans les couches supérieures
de la société de l'âge viking euh on ne s'attendrait pas à
ce que
des gens normaux soient enterrés avec
un objet aussi précieux qu'un navire que
très peu de personnes auraient  les
atouts pour
faire une offrande d'un
objet aussi précieux
et il pourrait bien sûr y avoir encore beaucoup
plus d'objets dans le navire
que nous trouverons dans les semaines à venir